- I love variations of this joke
because everyone hates
lawyers until you need one.
And then, then who you gonna call?
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
♪Ghost Busters. ♪
Meme Review, trademarked of PewDiePie.
All rights reserved.
All right, let's just get at it.
Legal memes, 2021 style.
Let's do it.
I graduated from Law School six years ago
with $250,000 of student loan debt.
After years of hard work
and tens of thousands
of dollars of payments,
I can officially say
now that I owe $315,000.
Very, very true.
Law School is extremely expensive.
$250,000, a quarter of a
million dollars for three years.
Not unusual if you are
making the minimum payments.
Yeah, that amount can
actually increase over time.
Now lawyers do tend to make more than
the national median salary
but that doesn't mean that
the amounts that they pay
for law school, aren't huge.
I know a lot of people who owe more now
than they did when they graduated.
And of course, a lot of people
rely on loan forgiveness.
They might work for a
public interest law firm
or they might work for the government,
in the hopes that over time
they will have their loans
forgiven by the government.
Which can happen.
There were talks of scaling that back,
but man, it's a, it's kind of a crapshoot.
You know what if you
leave the government job
it's it can really work
out poorly sometimes, so.
♪Toss a coin to your lawyer. ♪
The first thing I learned in law school
is to check how long something
is before I start reading it.
This is actually really,
really good advice.
Not all cases are created equal.
In law school you get these casebooks,
you are supposed to read these cases,
but some cases are 20, 30, 50 pages long
and other cases are condensed
and they might only be two pages long.
And the amount of information that
you're probably going to take
from each one of these cases
is about the same.
Everyone has a limited
amount of time in Law School.
I have a whole course on how
to do well in Law School.
And time management is a
huge, huge portion of that.
Knowing that you might
have to skim one case,
as opposed to reading one case in depth
and maybe knowing ahead of time,
which cases are the important ones
and which ones are filling
in some background idea.
Super, super important.
This guy gets it for sure.
All right keeping with
the Law School theme.
Law School has taught
me the valuable skill
of discussing the readings
without having read the readings
#LawStudentProblems.
Yeah the other part of that would be
sometimes you're not able to
get to all of the readings.
It takes forever to read these cases
and you might have literally
hundreds of pages to read,
per night in Law School.
Now there's a whole cottage
industry of supplements
that help you get through this
and synthesize everything into smaller,
more manageable pieces.
But sometimes there's
just way too much reading
and you have to let things slip.
Of course, you have to worry
about the Socratic method.
So that if you're not prepared in class,
the professor might call
on you, he might grill you.
And you might not have done the reading
and that doesn't turn out well,
just, you know see what
happens in Legally Blonde.
- Now, I assume all of you have read
pages 1 through 48 and are now well versed
in subject matter jurisdiction.
- Which is quasi-realistic, I guess.
Okay, out of the Law School
and into the practice.
When you check in with the clerk
and try to get priority,
with the sunglass shades.
So here's the background here.
Every courthouse has a court clerk,
they're an administrative official
but they can sort of control your destiny.
There might be a court clerk
for the whole courthouse
and there might be a court
clerk for the particular judge
that you're in front of.
And they control the
calendars of the judges.
So sometimes you should probably
spend some time getting
to know your court clerk.
At least being nice.
There's so many lawyers who
are just really, really mean
to these court clerks.
Thinking that they're,
you know beneath them
to talk to them.
But in reality a court clerk is the grease
that makes the wheels
of the courthouse work.
So, you better be nice
and you know metaphorically
slide into their DMS I guess.
I hate citations why
can't you just trust me?
(laughs heartily)
Oh my gosh.
Having practiced law for, I
don't know, 12 or 13 years now,
citations are the lifeblood
of any legal brief.
You have to cite any proposition of law
that you're saying to the judge,
otherwise court and council will look at
whatever you have just said
with a great deal of suspicion.
No one's going to trust your citations.
And the funny thing is
when we do scripts here
on Legal Eagle, you don't usually see it
but the scripts have on
average 75 or a 100 citations
because we had to do a lot of research
because we can't get these things wrong.
Whether we're putting
something in front of the judge
or putting something in front
of all the people on YouTube,
the citations are important.
And although you might
not see the citations
they are definitely there.
Unemployment checks,
murder hornets, quarantine,
loan debt, Coronavirus.
I'll go to law school.
That's fine.
Oh my God.
Yeah, so shed a tear for the law students
who have been going to law
school in 2020 and 2021,
it's completely different.
It's all virtual.
You are losing out on a
whole lot of the advantages
of law school.
And it's, it's really unfortunate.
And not only is it, you know,
the whole world is sort
of on fire or whatever,
but yeah to add Law School on top of that
and you don't even get to
interact with people in person.
Now, maybe that's a good thing
'cause you're not getting
the stress by proxy
of all your fellow law students.
Man, that would be really tough to add on
all of this stuff with law school stuff.
Though on the other hand, you know
you're not going to interact
with a whole lot of people
normally in Law School anyway.
So maybe it's best to get
Law School out of the way
while everyone is cooped up.
And then, you know, you
can leave Law School
and reenter society like
a normal human being.
Maybe that's not so bad.
Which Supreme Court
Justice flushed the toilet
on today's conference call.
Oh man, this was a huge, huge deal.
Someone actually flushed the toilet,
while an oral argument
with the Supreme Court.
Now the Supreme Court famously
doesn't allow video cameras
inside of the courthouse itself.
So, you get a bunch of these like oil
and pen paintings of people,
while they're presenting an oral argument.
But now in the Coronavirus times,
they have had to adapt
and they had to go to a dial
in voice conference system.
And of course, one of
the first oral arguments
that this was happening,
someone wasn't on mute
and you could hear a toilet
flushing in the background.
- And what the FCC has said is that
when the subject matter of the fall ranges
to topics, then the call is transformed.
- John Roberts must have been apoplectic
because he cares about how
the court is perceived.
And if there's plumbing in the background
of an oral argument
you can just imagine how
furious he must have been.
Not, not great for the, the
image of the Supreme Court.
All right.
What Law School looks
like from Facebook user
Trust Me, I'm a Lawyer.
I mean, this is this is actually
what Law School looks like.
This is not a joke.
So one of these books is a case book
and then a couple of these
books are supplements.
I think there's another case book.
And then there are obviously
tons and tons of highly.
I would say that this
actually under represents,
how much highlighting and inner lineation
and note-taking you actually take.
And little plastic flags in the book.
Law students actually have
to deal with this crap.
All right, how they welcome
newly hired associates to a law firm.
Some of you may die
but it's a sacrifice I'm willing to make.
So here's the thing with big firms
they pay a huge amount of money.
They expect for you to
basically devote your life
to the big firm when you
are a young associate
and they will actually
train you how to be a lawyer
at the highest levels of jurisprudence.
I actually think it's
a reasonable trade off.
I was in the big firm world for 10 years.
And I learned to practice at
the absolute highest levels
of Federal Court, in high
level State Court proceedings.
For a long time, I was completely
devoted to that big firm.
And I actually wouldn't
trade that forever.
You know the phrase, they don't
pay me enough for this crap.
Well, big firms actually do
pay you enough for that crap.
Whatever that crap is,
you kind of have to do it.
And it's a reasonable trade off
because Law School doesn't
really teach you how
to be a lawyer.
You have to learn that on the job.
Not for everyone.
It's hard to get into
but the trade-off is sometimes worth it.
When you start working at your
first job after Law School.
I don't bleep know about bleep.
All right I think we have to
probably bleep that one out.
So as I was just saying, you
graduate from Law School,
you don't know anything.
You don't know bleep about bleep.
So true, which is why it's
often a good idea to work
for a big firm
or another experienced lawyer
who knows what they're doing
'cause when you graduate from Law School
you don't know anything.
All right.
In keeping with the practice,
me coming up with multiple
good points after the hearing.
Oh, with the drag on the cigarette.
It happens every time.
well of the time, because
you're at oral argument,
you're at a hearing
and in the spur of the moment the judge
has some crazy question.
You really, really try and
shed this as hard as you can.
You come up with as many
arguments as you can.
You talk with your coworkers,
you talk with your friends,
you try and come up with every
argument you possibly can
but inevitably, there's
going to be something
you didn't think of.
And of course the second
that you leave the courthouse
you think of all of these great arguments
that you could have made.
And you didn't
C'est la vie.
- All right, I shall
grant you three wishes.
I wish for a world without lawyers.
Done you have no more wishes.
But you said three.
Sue me.
I love variations of this joke
because everyone hates
lawyers until you need one.
And then, then who you gonna call?
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
♪Ghost Busters! ♪
- All right.
The judge throughout our case,
don't worry I brought it back to him.
A legal Corgi, ah.
Legal Corgis have become a real thing.
I think it was partially
because of George Conway
and his love of Corgis.
And there are a couple
other legal commentators
that just have Corgis and love them.
So they've sort of been appropriated
as the dog of the legal profession.
This is a good boy.
He brought his case back.
First, we'll file a
baseless voter fraud claim.
Then it will be 12(b)(6)'d with prejudice.
Then we'll get rule 11 sanctions.
So, this pretty much sums up
all of the elections cases, in general.
A 12(b)(6) is famously a motion
to dismiss in federal court.
It is something that you file
when the claims themselves
don't rise to the level of a legal claim,
as a matter of law.
And then when that is filed,
then you can get rule 11 sanctions against
the counter party.
Though actually, Ooh, I
don't think this is accurate
because rule 11 sanctions
require you to file a motion
for rule 11 sanctions.
Then the other party gets
a safe harbor provision.
They can withdraw their
offending pleading.
I'd have to check the case law on this,
but I'm not sure if you get the
case dismissed on a 12(b)(6)
they can then go back
and get rule 11 sanctions
because at that point, the
case has already been dismissed
and you weren't able to
allow them the safe harbor
and the withdrawal.
So you might have to
file your rule 11 motion
before you file your 12(b)(6).
I'll have to think about that.
Perhaps not an accurate legal
meme here, I don't know.
You know, I would have
expected more legal accuracy
from Pixar or Dreamworks or
whichever this, what is it?
Minions, Mastermind.
I can't remember.
Is my client guilty, probably
but probably is not good enough.
I've actually never
heard it said that way,
but this this is accurate.
So, if you are talking about guilt,
then you are in the criminal law world,
which means that you're talking about
the standard of beyond a reasonable doubt.
Probably just means
that you are 51% short.
Now probably can also encompass
more certainty than that.
But probably in my mind
brings up these civil
standard of preponderance
of the evidence.
Which again is just barely more than 50%
more likely than not.
So, you've got the defense
case and the plaintiff's case.
And whichever one is more likely
that's who you have to find for.
Civil cases don't have a beyond
a reasonable doubt standard.
I probably would not argue
this in a criminal context,
but it is true.
If you only probably think
that someone committed
a criminal crime then you
can't find them guilty.
That's not good enough.
Okay, it looks like we're
back to Law School again.
First day of Med School,
each of you is brilliant
and will change the world.
Here's a white coat go and do well.
First day of Law School,
you're all dumb for doing this.
The four of you who survive
will work for evil corporations.
Here's a 100 page reading assignment.
It's due two hours from now.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll have to talk to
Dr. Mike about this one.
I don't know if they actually
said you're all brilliant
and here's a white lab coat on day one.
I kind of doubt that.
I'll have to find out from him.
The Law School stuff is a
little bit more accurate.
Though while, there are definitely
100 page reading assignments.
They aren't due two hours from now
and there's really no assignment.
You don't really get tested
until the very end of the semester.
Which I think is actually worse.
Instead of having lots
of little assignments
to do along the way,
you're only tested by really
one big assignment at the end.
And sometimes there might
be a midterm in the middle.
Now more than four people
are going to survive
and not all of them are going
to work for evil corporations
but definitely, yeah, some
of them, some of them will.
All right, going with
How I Met Your Mother,
ways in which your wrong
ways in which I am right.
Lawyered.
I loved Marshall in How I Met Your Mother.
There's one particular episode
where he's being wined and
dined by a giant law firm.
We've talked a lot about
giant law firms today.
It's so funny because he's
being wined and dined,
not only with Kobe steak,
but also Kobe lobster.
Which is lobster that's been
fed nothing but Kobe steak.
- You can really taste
the beef in that lobster.
- I think that is one of the funniest
and most accurate depictions
of being wined and dined,
by these, you know, huge law firms,
they are going to work you to death
but at least you'll get a
nice steak dinner out of it.
Made non-equity partner.
So I guess you could say things
are getting pretty serious.
Oh, this is a deep cut.
Let me see if I can explain this.
In the law firm world, you have partners,
the partners are the bosses.
They tend to be the
managers, the supervisors
and there are two kinds of partners.
There's an equity partner
who shares in the profits of a law firm.
And then there's a non-equity partner,
that is basically just a senior associate
that gets a nice title and
maybe some more responsibility.
And on top of that, they
probably have to pay into
the partnership as well.
So, it's kind of the worst of all worlds.
You don't get all that much more.
You don't share in a
profit sharing agreement
with the firm itself because
you don't have any equity.
So yeah things are getting pretty serious.
Cause there not.
- Geez.
- Oh my God, I'm going to
get so many phone calls
from my friends who are
non-equity partners in law firms.
Yeah well sucks to be them.
My face when someone argues,
when the ruling is in their favor
with the Tucker confused face.
Oh, this is so great.
I have seen so many lawyers who just,
they can't help themselves.
They really like to hear the
sound of their own voice.
And so they're in a hearing
they're winning with the judge.
The judge is going to rule in their favor
and they just keep talking.
Pro-tip if the judge is
going to rule in your favor,
shut up.
And I have seen lawyers
snatch defeat from the jaws of victory
because they just want to keep talking.
All right, speaking of mercurial judges,
when both parties agreed to a continuance,
but the judge denies it.
This happens so much too.
So again, the judge through their proxy,
the court clerk can
set their own schedule.
And oftentimes both parties
will agree to a continuance
of a hearing or trial or whatever,
but the parties don't get
to agree to these things.
They have to get the judge
to sign off on these things.
And the judge is gonna judge.
Especially in Federal Court,
where the judge just doesn't
care about anyone else
'cause they are the master
of their own universe.
A salt with a deadly weapon.
Oh, that's cute.
I think everybody gets this one.
No explanation needed.
MPS esquire says, do you wear glasses
and a face mask due to COVID-19
if so, you may be
entitled to condensation.
So true.
Look I'm going to laugh at dad jokes.
I just am.
Sorry.
Hey this magic eight ball
just keeps saying it depends.
Oh, that's the special lawyer edition.
Oh, I mean, you guys know this.
It always depends.
The law is complicated.
Facts are complicated.
You're going to ask me a legal question
and I'm going to tell you it depends.
So ooh, that's a great merch idea.
Would you guys buy that?
A special Legal Eagle
edition of a magic eight ball
that just says it depends on every role.
Hmm.
All right and the next meme is
I wanted to be a lawyer
but I didn't have the stomach for it.
It's a shark.
Look you gotta be a shark sometimes
when especially when you're in litigation,
not so much if you're
a transactional lawyer
but even if you are a transactional lawyer
sometimes you have to have those kinds
of killer instincts to get
the business deals done
but the litigators
certainly need to have
shark like instincts
or even more than shark like instincts
because the sharks sometimes
don't have the stomach for it.
But of course seeing this shark
makes me really want to go to the beach
because the weather is
getting so much nicer
but of course my allergies
are getting terrible.
That...
(sneezes abruptly)
You know what allergies be damned.
I am going to the beach,
the weather is too nice
and of course, to do that,
I have to change out of
my custom Indochino suit
and wear something more casual.
And for that, I turn to Mack Weldon.
If I'm not in court or on
a zoom call with a judge.
I'm often wearing Mack Weldon
or I'm at home wearing pajamas.
But Mack Weldon is my choice
for wearing stuff outside of the house,
which I haven't done in seemingly forever
because they focus on smart
design and premium fabrics.
Mack Weldon is probably best well known
for their insanely
comfortable boxer briefs.
Including their brand
new stealth boxer brief.
Which is great for working
out or just hanging out.
I wish I could show you
one, but oh, wait a minute.
These things so comfortable.
I forgot I was actually wearing them.
I wish you could feel
how comfortable this is.
It's insanely comfortable.
And if you're watching this
channel you're probably an adult
and you probably deserve
to have nice boxer briefs.
And I can tell you, it
makes a world of difference.
I also love they're incredibly
comfortable polos like these
and they're radius pants.
Which are halfway between
slacks and joggers.
So I don't have to choose
between wearing something
incredibly comfortable
like sweat pants
and looking presentable
like an actual human being
when I decide to actually leave the house
and speaking of which
I don't even have to leave
the house to order Mack Weldon
just order multiple sizes,
have them shipped to my home
and just return the ones
that don't fit right
and keep the ones that fit perfectly.
So, if you would like to try Mack Weldon
you can get 20% off your first order.
Just go to MackWeldon.com/legaleagle
or use the promo code
Legal Eagle at checkout
or of course you can
click on the link below
in the description, which
really helps out this channel.
And of course Mack
Weldon's loyalty program
will get you 20% off plus free shipping
and access to new products
before everybody else.
It's automatic when you sign up and order
at mackweldon.com/legaleagle.
So as we all reenter society
you owe it to yourself
to get some insanely comfortable,
great looking clothes
from Mack Weldon.
And of course, if you want to
try their famous boxer briefs
and you decide for any reason
that you're not satisfied
you can just keep them
and still get a refund
because nobody wants to
return used underwear.
So again, just click on the link
and go to mackweldon.com/legaleagle
or use the promo code legaleagle
for 20% off your first order
and clicking on those links
really helps out this channel
and it'll help you look fly.
So do you have some legal memes
or some legal jokes that
I should respond to?
Please let me know in the comments below
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other
real lawyer reactions.
And of course my famous legal meme review.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.